GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO WASHINGTON.
I'M BRET BAIER.
CONGRESSIONAL DEMOCRATS NOW IN
CONTROL DEMANDING A MOUNTAIN OF
DOCUMENTS ON VARIOUS TOPICS.
IN A FLURRY OF LETTERS SENT OUT
TODAY TO 81 INDIVIDUALS,
AGENCIES, AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS TIED TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS HE WILL
COOPERATE WITH A GREATLY
EXPANDED DEMOCRATIC PROBE INTO
HIS CONDUCT.
THE HEAD OF THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE SAYS IT'S VERY CLEAR
IN HIS MIND THE PRESIDENT HAS
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE.
YET, NEW YORK COMMERCE MEANT
JERROLD NADLER SAYS IT'S TOO
SOON TO TALK ABOUT IMPEACHMENT.
REPUBLICANS SAY THIS IS ALL
POLITICAL, LAYING THE GROUNDWORK
FOR THE DEMOCRATS IMPEACHMENT
MOVE.
WE HAVE FOX TEAM COVERAGE.
BRIT HUME HAS ANALYSIS OF THE
INVESTIGATIONS IN THE FALL OUT.
WE BEGIN WITH CHIEF INTELLIGENCE
CORRESPONDENT CATHERINE HERRIDGE
AND THE DETAILS.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
WITH SUBPOENA POWER IN THE
GAVEL, HOUSE DEMOCRATS LAUNCHING
INVESTIGATIONS THAT GO FAR
BEYOND RUSSIA.
HOUSE REPUBLICANS SAY IT'S NOT A
SEARCH FOR THE TRUTH BUT AN
EFFORT TO DAMAGE THE PRESIDENT.
>> I COOPERATE ALL THE TIME WITH
EVERYBODY.
YOU KNOW THE BEAUTIFUL THING.
IT'S ALL A HOAX.
>> >> PRESIDENT TRUMP RESPONDER
>> >> PRESIDENT TRUMP RESPONDES
>> >> PRESIDENT TRUMP RESPONDET
>> >> PRESIDENT TRUMP RESPONDEO
HOUSE DEMOCRATS SEEKING RECORDS.
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE
2016 CAMPAIGNED TO HIS
BUSINESSES AND FAMILY MEMBERS.
>> WE'LL BE ISSUING DOCUMENT
REQUESTS.
>> JUSTIFYING PROBES INTO
CORRUPTION, OBSTRUCTION, AND
ABUSE OF POWER, THE, THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE'S DEMOCRATIC
CHAIRMAN SAID SPECIAL COUNSEL
ROBERT MUELLER'S RUSSIA FOCUS IS
TOO NARROW.
>> WE CAN'T DEPEND ON THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION FOR THIS.
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION,
NUMBER ONE, WE DON'T KNOW WHEN
IT'S ENDING, DESPITE RUMORS.
NUMBER TWO, ITS FOCUS ON
SPECIFIC CRIMES.
>> HOUSE MINORITY LEADER
COUNTERED THAT THE PRESIDENT'S
FORMER PERSONAL ATTORNEY MICHAEL
COHEN SHOULDERS AND A LOT OF THE
BLAME.
FOR POTENTIAL LEGAL EXPOSURE OR
PAYMENTS TO SILENCE STORMY
DANIELS DURING THE ELECTION.
>> FIVE HIRE AN ATTORNEY TO MAKE
SURE I CARRY OUT THE LAW, THE
ATTORNEY HAS A RESPONSIBILITY TO
TELL ME WHAT'S RIGHT AND WRONG.
IT'S A FINANCE CAMPAIGN, THOSE
ARE FINE.
THEY ARE NOT IMPEACHABLE.
>> WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
CONFIRMED "THE COUNSEL'S OFFICE
AND RELEVANT WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS WILL REVIEW IT AND
RESPOND AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME."
CONGRESSIONAL REPUBLICANS SAID
THE WIDE-RANGING INVESTIGATIONS
ARE ABOUT 2020 AND THE ACCUSED
DEMOCRATS OF SHIFTING THE
GOALPOST.
NOW THAT THEY BELIEVE THE RUSSIA
COLLUSION COVER IS APPARENTLY
BARE.
>> THE INVESTIGATION IS
CHANGING, DEVELOPING.
WE HAVE BEEN INVESTIGATING
COLLUSION AND OBSTRUCTION.
THEY HAVE LEFT THAT FAR BEHIND.
THEY HAVE WRITTEN OFF MUELLER.
>> REPUBLICANS REFOCUSING ON THE
ANTI-TRUMP DOSSIER AFTER A
FLORIDA RULED THAT A DEPOSITION
FROM CHRISTOPHER STEELE CAN BE
UNSEALED.
RECORDS EXPECTED TO REVEAL HOW
THE DEMOCRAT FUNDED OPPOSITION
RESEARCH CAME THROUGH CHANNELS
TO THE FBI IN AN EFFORT TO LEND